[Musique]
mais tout de suite puisque je vois qu en
ce lendemain de fête vous avez du mal à
concentrer votre attention sur vos
informations régionales
je vous propose une enquête de pierre
yves mervin savez vous qu'il existe
aujourd'hui de nouvelles thérapeutiques
tout à fait propre à soulager ceux qui
ont quelque peu abusé de la dive
bouteille une enquête pointu de pierre
yves morvan donc sur des images
remarquablement net d'hubert tilloy ce
type je crois que l'acupuncture à une
possibilité de rétablissement lesquels
c'est quand même curieux ça ça veut dire
que l'acupuncture ne n'envisage pas la
même de la même manière
l'alcoolisme si vous voulez la queue
pour l'acupuncture c'est de
l'énergétique
alors si vous voulez l'alcool c'est de
l'énergie positive qui entrent dans nos
organismes et et augmente l'énergie
positif de l'organisme alors comme dans
l'organisme il ya un équilibre entre le
positif et le négatif ce qu'on appelle
en acupuncture liang et le yang montrent
la demande vers le veau et le in descend
vers le bas et cet échange entre le haut
et le bas permanents permet l'équilibré
la bonne la bonne santé quand on a bu de
l'alcool séduit yang l'alcool cède
impose de l'inde du positif dans le
positif augmente d'un organisme et il ya
barrages il ya le lion augmente
énormément vers le haut
et quand il va descendre il se bloque et
dans cette sensation de yang de yang
yang ça veut dire de beaucoup de yang
dans la tête et essayant dans la tête
provoquent tout laissant prendre des
billets t et cette sensation qu'on a
après avoir bien vu alors vous pouvez
intervenir de quelle façon dans des cas
semblables pour défouler quelqu'un en
acupuncture
oui on acupuncture la première le
premier geste qu'on doit faire c'est
d'abord à langer le malade pour que
favoriser
le passage de in vers le yang et de yang
vers le green d'une façon horizontale
deuxièmement il ya des points en
acupuncture qu'on utilise ect ect prêt
spécifique pour l'état d'ivresse ou sans
aller jusqu'à l'ivresse mais aussi quand
on a cette sensation qu'on a après avoir
bien vu on a des points d'acupuncture et
quand nous médecins acupuncteurs on
traite le malade avec des aiguilles
évidemment les gens n'ont pas des
aiguilles chez eux et non neutraliser
pas peuvent pas utiliser cette méthode
n'empêche que les gens peuvent utiliser
des points d'acupuncture par massage ce
qu'on appelle massot acupuncture qui
permet de revenir à une sensation normal
et ce sont des points très spécifique
est pas compliqué que je vous montre ici
car il ya un point juste au dessous du
genou
ça veut dire en prenant ces quatre
doigts en mettant le premier au niveau
de la rotule partie supérieure entende
en bas vers une dépression qui est la
tête la tête du tibia là dans la
dépression et à un point d'ailleurs qui
devient douloureux quand on est dans
cette situation là est alors en presse
ce point est en le mas et on doit le mas
et de bas de vos tombes à il ya notre
point aussi qui est merveilleux pour ce
cadre là mais qui se trouvent en nombre
supérieur et qui se trouve carrément sur
entre le premier et le deuxième doit si
vous si vous faites ça vous allez tomber
ici sur un petit petit
renflement ronflements et vous prenez
vous prenez le doigt et vous et vous
presser et vous allez sentir une douleur
et à ce moment là il faut la masse et
aussi vers alors celle là ils vont la
masse et vers le bas
ça veut dire qu'il faut la disperser
donc vous prenez le doigt ici vous
presser c'est douloureux et vous masser
comme ça de haut en bas vers le bout du
doigt
puis il ya un point qui est très bien
qui permet la respiration énergétique et
prendre le souffle et l'oxygène c'est le
point qui se trouve au milieu entre les
deux mêmes l'ont alors ce moment-là ce
point là qui ici ça s'appelle vie 7j m17
vaisseau conception il faut le mince et
2 2 bat en vo dans le sens donc vous
massez ça vers l'euro et le sujet enfin
la personne façon de ressentir une
sensation de respiration profonde et va
revenir à lui alors il ya un point très
important
et alors et il n'est utilisé que lorsque
la personne est en état des sous
inconscience en conscience brest à ce
moment vous prenez un objet pointu c'est
pas un canif g pointu quand même et il
faut masser le bout du nez ce qu'on
appelle ce qu'on voit ici écrire tm 25
ça c'est un point qui est anti ivresse
et qui est croyez-moi très efficace est
merveilleux il suffit de l'essayer pour
avoir pour se rendre compte en ce qui
concerne oreilles si vous regardez bien
l'oreille c'est un foetus à l'envers un
regard des sas et la tête et ça vient
comme ça c'est une fête us à l'envers
alors pour la région céphalique c'est le
lot bulle de l'oreille qui est intéressé
à ce moment là en masse les points qui
sont douloureux parce que quand on passe
ce de l'objet
non coupant un objet un big par exemple
sur l'endroit sur leur bulle
on trouve des points très douloureux à
ce moment là il faut les masses et donc
en masse les points douloureux selon
bull de l'oreille et au mas cette région
là qui correspond à l'abdomen donc à
tous le phénomène gastrique hépatique
vésiculaire est donc vous masser en
masse ici bien et c'est m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]